the next question is okay
trump was given this framework by
attorney john eastman
here's how pence
could overturn the election
we now know on january 4th eastman said
to trump this plan is illegal okay let's
dig a little more into that
when did eastman know that it was
illegal well he seemed to know it very
very thoroughly and significantly we're
going to look at a clip here former
trump white house lawyer eric hirschman
okay says
he spoke with eastman on january 7th and
told him you'd better get a great effing
criminal defense lawyer because you're
going to need it
not long after that
eastman started asking for a pardon from
donald trump
he knew
his suggestion was criminal let's take a
look at this clip mr hershman's account
of that call
the day after
uh
eastman
i don't remember why he called me and he
or he texted me or called me
want to talk with me and he said he
couldn't reach others
and he started to
ask me about
something dealing with georgia and
preserving something potentially for
appeal
and
i said to him
are you out of your f in mind
right
i said i
said i only want to hear two words
coming out of your mouth from now on
orderly transition
now the screamer said i don't want to
hear any other fn words coming out of
your mouth no matter what other than
orderly transition repeat those words to
me
eventually you said orderly transition
i said good john now i'm going to give
you the best free legal advice you're
ever getting in your life
get a great fn criminal defense lawyer
you're going to need it
right and then i hung up on them
he knew they all knew that this was
criminal what they were trying to do and
then we also now have thanks to the
committee the email we have an email
from eastman
uh saying
i've decided
i should be on the pardon list if that
is still in the works eastman was so
sure
that what he had done
was criminal and exposed him to
prosecution
that he wanted a pardon from then
president donald trump
these are not good people and they all
knew it was against the law and there
were other lawyers saying hey to the
group that's pushing this stuff you need
lawyers remember maga means making
attorneys get attorneys and that you
know rudy ended up with an attorney
michael cohen ended up with it's just
that's what it is par for the course and
they were saying all you people should
go and get yourselves criminal defense
attorneys eastman knew
and trump was at least told
incredible revelations from the
committee let's next talk
about this idea of hang mike pence
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board-certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but
i can do it all on my phone i don't have
to spend hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets fifteen dollars off
your first dermatology visit go to
apostrophe dot com slash pacman and use
the code pacman the link is in the
description